ก็
สวัสดีค่ะเฮียตี๋สวัสดีครับน้องเรียม
สวัสดีครับนักเรียน
เย้นักเรียนของหน้ากลับมาเจอกับพี่
อาร์ตี้กับน้องเรียมกันนะครับณวันนี้วัน
นี้เรามาเจอกันวันอะไรครับวันนี้
วันนี้
ใช่วันอะไร
วันพุธหน้าใช่แล้วครับวันนี้วันพุธวันพุธ
ที่เท่าไหร่ครับวันนี้
วันพุธที่ 20 ค่ะ 5 วันพุธที่ 20 วันพุธ
ที่ 20 เดือนอะไรครับเดือนนี้
เดือนเมษายนค่ะค่ะเดือนเมษายนนะครับโอเค
วันพุธที่ 20 เดือนเมษายนปีปีพตอะไรครับ
ปีนี้
ข้อศ.
165 ใช่ครับพ.ศ.
2565 แล้วปีคศอะไรครับ
ข้อ
2022 หาท้ายครับข้อศ. 2020  2 โอเคอ่ะ
แล้ววันนี้ตอนนี้ที่เราคุยกันอยู่ตอนนี้
ครับกี่โมงแล้วครับ
ตอนนี้
13:00 นหลัง 15 บ่ายโมง 35 นาทีโอเคครับ
เออ cm นะโอเคอะวันนี้วันนี้เดี๋ยวเพียง
ตี้มีเรื่องเล่าเรื่องเล่าเป็นเรื่อง
เกี่ยวกับเอ่อ
เกี่ยวกับเรื่องสมัยโบราณของคนไทยที่คน
ไทยหลายๆคนน่าจะรู้จักดีอ่ะอ่าเพื่อที่
คิดว่าเรื่องเนี้ยน้องเรียมก็เคยฟังแล้ว
เคยขอฟังแล้วเออ
ใช่ครับเป็นรถเกี่ยวกับใครคะอ่ะเป็น
เรื่องเกี่ยวกับอ่ะผู้ชายคนนึงที่ที่เอ่อ
รูปหล่อแล้วก็มีมีภรรยาหลายคน
ห่าใจครับหือ
อร่อยกันนึกออกมั้ยเรื่องอะไรครับอ่ะมีมี
ผู้ชายสองคนในเรื่องนี้มีผู้ชายอยู่ 2 คน
แล้วก็มีผู้หญิง 1 คน
อ่าใช่ครับผู้ชายสองคนเนี้ยผู้ชายสองคน
นี้ก็รักกับผู้หญิงคนเดียวกัน
ผู้ชายหล่อหล่อสองคนเลยนะคะอ้าผู้ชายหล่อ
1 คนอีกคนนึงไม่หล่อไม่หล่อแต่ว่ารวยรวย
มีเงินเยอะอ่ามีเงิน 1  8 ไม่หล่อ
ขอเอ็มคิดว่าคิดออกแล้วฮ่าๆๆเรื่องอะไร
ครับคิดว่าเรื่องอะไรให้นักเรียนมทายครับ
เรื่องที่มีผู้ชายคนหนึ่งชื่อขุนแผนใช่
ไหมคะอ่าใช่ครับนะมีผู้ชายคนนึงชื่อขุน
แผนนี่ครับนะมีขุนแผนนิสัยคือ 1 คุณน้าคน
นี้ชื่อขุนช้างใช่ครับขุนแผนเนี่ยหล่อ
หล่อแล้วก็เก่งด้วยเก่งเก่งขุนแผนเนี่ย
เป็นเอ่อนักรบเป็นนักรบใช้ครับส่วนคุณ
ช้างเนี่ยคุณช้างเป็นคนที่รวยมีเงินมาก
แต่ไม่หล่อไม่หล่อตัวอ้วนช้างตัวอ้วนนะ
อ้วนเหมือนช้างอ้วนเหมือนช้างก็เลยเรียก
ว่าคุณช้างอ้าวช้างตัวใหญ่เพลงช้างตัว
ใหญ่ห่าไปหาคนนี้คุณแผนกับคุณช้างทั้งสอง
คนเนี่ยเป็นเพื่อนกันรู้จักกันรู้จักกัน
นะครับน้าแล้วคุณช้างขุนช้างกับขุนแผน
เนี่ยก็มีเพื่อนผู้หญิงอยู่อีกคนนึงนะอ่า
มีเพื่อนผู้หญิงอยู่ดีคนนึงเพื่อนผู้หญิง
คนนี้เนี่ยอ่าชื่อ
วันออกนี้ครับชื่อวันทองอาว่าวันทองเป็น
คนสวยนะคะพี่อะไรครับวันทองเป็นผู้หญิง
ที่สวยมากอาจขุนแผนก็ชอบกับวันทองหน้าขุน
แผนรักกับวันทองนะครับคุณช้างขุนช้างก็
เข้ารักวันองเหมือนกันแต่แต่แต่ว่านาง
วันทองเนี่ยไม่ได้รักขุนช้าง
แม่นางวันทองไม่รักขุนช้างนั่ง
นางวันทองรักขุนแผนน่ารักขุนแผนนะครับ
ก็เลยทั้งทั้งนางวันทอง
แล้วก็ขุนแผนรักกันก็เลยแต่งงานกัน
นะครับเอาโอเคแต่งงานกายครับแต่งงานกัน
แล้วก็อยู่ด้วยกันขุนแผนก็เป็นสามีคุณแผน
ก็เป็นสามีนะครับส่วนวันทองก็เป็นภรรยา
กันให้อยู่ด้วยกันมาแล้วก็มีลูกด้วยครับ
มีลูกคนหนึ่ง
อายุด้วยกันจนมีตู้ชื่ออะไรคะเนี่ยตีลูก
ลูกของขุนแผนกับวันทองชื่อว่าพลายงาม
อ้าเป็นผู้ชายหรือผู้หญิงค่ะเป็นผู้ชาย
ครับทรายงามมีทรายงามเป็นผู้ชายแอบถ่ายจะ
เป็นชื่อของช้างตัวผู้ชื่อของลูกช้างนะ
เราก็จะเรียกว่าพลาย
ถ่ายอ่าใช่ครับเป็นเด็กผู้ชายนะครับหน้า
ชื่อว่าพรายงาม
อาแล้วก็อ่าทั้งคู่ก็อยู่โอเคแล้วนะ
ทำงานมีลูกจบเนี่ยติดได้ครับอ่ะยังไม่จบ
ค่ะยังไม่จบอ่ะอ่ามีอยู่วันนึงอ่ะมีอยู่
วันนึงขุนแผนเนี่ยขุนแผนเป็นคนที่เก่ง
เก่งนะครับมีความสามารถในการสู้รบหน้า
แล้วก็มีตอนนั้นมีสงครามมีสงครามเกิดขึ้น
ที่ประเทศไทยนะครับแล้วขุนแผนเนี่ยก็รบ
เก่งขึ้นขุนแผนก็เลยต้องไปรบต้องไปรบนี่
ครับขุนแผนก็ไปรบจะต่อสู้กับข้าศึกนะครับ
ขุนแผนก็ไปต่อสู้กับข้าศึกไปรบขุนแผนก็
ไม่ได้อยู่ที่บ้านขุนแผนก็ปล่อยให้ให้
วันทองเลี้ยงลูกอยู่ที่บ้านอยู่ที่บ้าน
ขุนแผนไปรบคนเดียว
หน้าวันทองไม่ได้ไปรายงามไม่ได้ไปอยู่ที่
บ้านครับ R แต่ก่อนไปใช่บ้านต้องรอขุนแผน
ไปลบลบเสร็จขุนแผนจะกลับมานะครับ
งา
แล้วตอนที่ตอนที่ขุนแผนก่อนที่ขุนแผนจะไป
รบขุนแผนก็คิดคิดว่าเอ่อทำยังไงถ้า
วันทองเนี่ยคิดถึงขุนแผนวันทองจะทำยังไง
เวลาคิดถึงคุณแผนอ้าขุนแผนก็เลยจะเอาต้น
ไม้ต้นไม้ให้วันทองไว้หนึ่งต้น
ข้าวอันทองคิดถึงขุนแผนวันทองก็มาดูแลต้น
ไม้มารดน้ำรดน้ำต้นไม้มาพรวนดินต้นไม้ดู
แลรักษาต้นไม้ให้เหมือนกับดูแลรักษาขุน
แผนหน้าเพราะขุนแผนจะไม่อยู่ขุนแผนจะไม่
อยู่ทราย
อา
แล้ววันทองก็วะครับ
ว่าสมัยก่อนนะมันไม่มีมันไม่มีต้นไม้ปลอม
ๆถ้าเป็นเนียมเรียนจะชอบแบบต้นไม้ปลอมที่
แบบพอไม่ต้องรดน้ำอ๋อ
ๆแต่วันทองก็ชอบมันทองก็ได้รดน้ำได้ดูแล
ต้นไม้ได้เห็นต้นไม้ออกใบออกใบใหม่ออกดอก
สวยๆวันทองก็มีความและแล้ววันทองก็คิดถึง
ขุนแผน
ได้นะ
ใช่ครับด้วยการดูแลต้นไม้ในครับอ๋อ
ๆครับพี่อ่ะแต่ว่าแต่ว่าตอนที่ขุนแผนไม่
อยู่แล้วขุนแผนไปรบ
น้องเรียมจำเพื่อนขุนแผนได้ไหม
จำขุนช้างได้ไหมช้าอ่าคุณได้ 5 ขุนช้าง
เนี่ยก็รักวันทองอ้ะแต่ตอนนั้นวันทองไม่
รักวันทองไม่รักขุนช้างหนาวันทองเนี่ยไม่
รักคุณช้าง
วันทองไม่รักแต่ตอนนี้ตอนนี้ขุนแผนไม่
อยู่ขุนแผนไม่อยู่คุณช้างก็เลยมาหาวันทอง
ทุกวัน
หน้ามาหาวันก่อนทุกวันยายครับน่ะเพราะๆ
วันศุกร์เสาร์อาทิตย์ๆครับ
ทุกวันใช้ครับหน้าเพื่อเพื่อที่จะให้
วันทองเนี่ยเพื่อที่จะให้วันทองเนี่ยรัก
คุณช้างบ้างหน้ามาทุกวันมาคุยทุกวันซื้อ
ของมาให้เพราะว่าคุณช้างเนี่ยรวยคุณทั้ง
มีเงินเยอะซื้อขนมมาให้วันทองซื้อของมา
ให้วันทองบ่อยๆในครับอ่า
ไม่ต้องไปลบเหรอคะอ่ะคุณช้างไม่ต้องไปรบ
เพราะว่าขุนช้างมีเงินเยอะคุณช้างจ่าย
เงินคุณช้างไม่ให้หลงให้หายอยากแล้วคุณ
ช้างก็ลบไม่เก่งด้วยคุณช้างอ้วนตัวใหญ่ลบ
ไม่เก่งๆก็เลยไม่ได้ไปรบคุณช้างก็เลยมาหา
นางวันทองทุกวันน๊าแล้วอ่ะแต่มีอยู่วัน
หนึ่งคุณช้างคุณช้างรู้ว่าขุนแผนเนี่ยฝาก
ต้นไม้ให้วันทองดูแลคุณช้างก็เลยคิดคิดนะ
ทำยังไงทำยังไงให้วันทองเนี่ยให้วันทอง
เนี่ยไม่คิดถึงขุนแผน
เพราะว่าถ้าวันทองมารดน้ำต้นไม้วันห้องมา
ดูแลต้นไม้วันทองก็จะคิดถึงขุนแผนใช่ไหม
หาอะไรคะมาขโมยต้นไม้าที่บ้านของคุณช้าง
คุณช้างไม่ได้ขโมยต้นไม้แต่คุณช้างคิดคิด
คิดจะทำยังไงดีให้ไม่มีต้นไม้คุณช้างก็
ไม่อยากได้ต้นไม้คุณช้างก็เลยคิดว่า a
ปกติต้นไม้เนี่ยนักเรียนเวลาน้องเรียมอ่า
ดูแลต้นไม้นักเรียนมรดน้ำต้นไม้รดน้ำอะไร
ที่ต้นไม้ครับ
รดน้ำร้อนรถใจเย็นรดน้ำเอ่อรถน้ำแข็งใช้
น้ำอะไรรดต้นไม้ครับ
ใช้น้ำใช่น้ำอ่าใช่ครับธรรมดาถึงน้าเพ็ญ
ไม่ได้ได้ครับแบบธรรมดาครับแต่ไม่ใช้น้ำ
ร้อนนะใจอ่ะสุดท้างสอนวิธีหาใช้ขับรถน้ำ
ร้อนไม่ได้คุณช้างรู้ว่ารดน้ำร้อนไม่ได้
เหมือนกันอ่าคุณช้างก็เลยคิดว่า 5 ทำให้
ต้นไม้ตายคุณช้างก็เลยเอาน้ำร้อนเอาน้ำไป
ต้มน้ำไปต้มให้เดือดค่าน้ำเดือนน้ำก็ร้อน
ใช่ไหมเอาน้ำร้อนไปรถไปรดต้นไม้ต้นไม้ของ
ขุนแผน
ห่าใช่ครับพอเอาน้ำร้อนไปรถก็คล้ายต้นไม้
เป็นยังไงอ่ะโอ๊ย
ตายในห้องหมายก็ตายครับน่ะต้นไม้ก็ตายก้น
ไม้ก็ตายอ้ะเพราะต้นไม้ตายวันทองก็เสียใจ
วันทองก็เสียใจเพราะว่าต้นไม้ตายนะครับ
อ่าแต่คุณช้างคุณช้างเป็นไงครับทีนี้คุณ
ช้างดีใจค้นหา EP ใจฮ่าๆๆเพราะว่าต้นไม้
ตายน้าเพราะคุณช้างเห็นวันทองร้องไห้ร้อง
ไห้คุณช้างก็เลยบอกบอกบอกวันทองบอกว่าขอ
ที่ต้นไม้ตายที่ต้นไม้ตายเนี่ยเป็นเพราะ
ว่าขุนแผนขุนแผนที่ไปรบเนี่ยขุนแผนก็ต่อ
ไปขุนแผนปลายนะครับหน้าต้นไม้ก็เลยตาย
ด้วยอ่าคุณแผนบอกวันพ่อขุนแผนโกหกขุนแผน
คู่นไม่จริง
หน้าแต่หน้าเหมือนห้องอ่ะอ้าใช่นางวันทอง
ก็ไม่รู้นะว่าท้องก็เลยเชื่อเชื่อที่
เชื่อที่คุณช้างบอกว่าขุนแผนนะตายแล้วเออ
ใช่ครับนางวันทองเชื่อแล้วก็ 4 เสียใจ
ร้องไห้ที่ขุนแผนต่ายนะครับอ่า
แล้วหลังจากนั้นขุนแผนก็เลยก็เลยชุด 5
ชุดหมายถึงขุนแผนก็เลยจับจับนางวันทอง
เนี่ยไปอยู่ที่ใบ้คุณช้างคุณช้างก็เลยจับ
นางวันทองเนี่ยไปอยู่ที่บ้านของตัวเองไป
อยู่บ้านของขุนแผนไอ้ขุนช้างชายจับไปนะ
วันทองก็ไม่อยากไปไม่อยากไปแต่คุณช้างก็
จับให้เอาวันทองไปอยู่ที่บ้านตัวเองนะ
ครับอ่าอีกแล้วพอไปอยู่ที่บ้านของขุนช้าง
นางวันทองก็เลยตกเป็นเมียของขุนช้าง
หน้าก็เลยอยู่ด้วยกันที่บ้านปู๊ดท้อง
เมื่อก่อนเป็นเมียหรือว่าเป็นภรรยาของขุน
แผนๆเมื่อก่อนเกลียดตอนนี้เปลี่ยน
ชัดใช่เป็นภรรยาของขุนช้างแทนนะครับเพราะ
วันทองคิดคิดว่าขุนแผนตายแล้ว
น่าใช้ครับแล้วก็ก็เลยต้องไปอยู่ไปอยู่
ที่บ้านของขุนช้างนะครับเออแล้วอยู่มาวัน
หนึ่งตอนที่ขุนแผนลบเสร็จแล้วคุณแผนลบ
เสร็จแล้วคุณแผนก็ปรับมาที่บ้านคุณแผน
กลับมาที่บ้านและกลับมาที่บ้านเจอนาง
วันทองไหมครับเจอไหม
มากมายไม่เจอคิดว่าแล้วผมวันชัยครับไอ้
เจอนางวันทองแล้วเพราะตอนนี้นางวันทองไป
อยู่กับคุณช้างใช่ไหมอ่าอ่ะ
ขุนแผนกลับมาที่บ้านก็มาเจอกับคนนี้เป็น
อ่ะไฟล์ทายงามท้ายงานตอนที่ขุนแผนไปเนี่ย
รายงานยังเป็นเด็กอยู่แต่ตอนนี้ภายงามโต
แล้วน่าตอนนี้ภายงานโตแล้วแม่คุณแผนเจอ
พ่อ
ค้ายังไงอ้ำเจอพ่อเจอขุนแผน
ขุนแผนเป็นลบลบเลือนนานมากๆใต้ตั้งแต่ใคร
น้ำโตได้ครับตอนนี้ภายงามโตแล้วให้งามก็
เลยบอกบอกพ่อบอกพ่อว่าเนี่ยแม่ถูกขุนช้าง
อ่ะจับตัวไปอยู่ที่บ้านของคุณชาร์จแล้ว
ห่าก็เลยทั้งคู่ก็จะพากันฆ่ากันไปไปพาตัว
แม่กลับมากลับมาอยู่ที่บ้านกลับไม่อยู่
กับลูกกลับมาอยู่กับขุนแผนเหมือนเดิมนะ
ครับน้าคนจบก็จบไหมไม่ตกครับไม่จบเพราะ
ว่าเพราะว่าขุนช้างครับคุณช้างเป็นไงคุณ
ช้างไม่ยอมคุณช้างเนี่ยไม่ยอมเพราะว่าคุณ
ช้างเนี่ยก็รักคุณช้างก็รักนางวันทอง
เหมือนกันเพราะว่าพานางวันทองไปอยู่ด้วย
กันตั้งนานแล้วก็เลยรักรักนางวันองแล้ว
ไม่อยากให้นางวันทองกลับมาอยู่กับขุนแผน
ขุนช้างก็เลยไปฟ้อง
ไปฟ้องครับค่าราชา
หน้าไปฟ้องเข้าราชาไปบอกพระราชาว่าขุนแผน
บ่เดี๋ยวจะหาว่าขุนแผนเนี่ยมาแย่งนาง
วันทองไป
พระราชาก็ไม่เชื่อราชาก็เป็นเรียกเรียก
ขุนแผนมาเรียกนางวันทองมาเรียกคุณช้างมา
มานี่มานี่มาคุยกันมาคุยกันเกิดอะไรขึ้น
ทรายอ่าให้ขุนแผนเล่าให้ฟังให้นางวันทอง
เล่าให้ฟังให้คุณช้างเล่าให้ฟังพระราชาก็
ฟังฟังแล้วก็คิดคิดคิดนะคิดว่าจะทำยังไง
ดีพระราชาก็เลยถามครับ
ถามนางวันทองไปถามนางวันทอง
ถามว่านางวันทองนางวันทองรักขุนแผนไหมอ่า
นางวันทองก็นั่งมันตอบว่าอะไรนางวันทองก็
ไม่ตอบเมียมันท้องเสียใจมากเสียใจมากตอน
นี้ถูกจับมานะมาท้องกลัวกลัวพระราชานวทอง
ไม่ตอบ
พระราชาถามอีกถามนางวันทองนางวันทองรัก
ขุนช้างไหมหน้าน้องก็ไม่ตอบ
ตายครับพระราชสาสน์ก็เลยคิดว่าทำยังไงดี
จะทำยังไงดีให้ขุนช้างโอเคให้ขุนแผนโอเค
ให้นาวรรณทองโอเคให้ทุกคนโอเค
ประชาก็เลยถามอีกครั้งหนึ่ง
บอกให้นางวันทองเลือกเลือกว่าณวันทอง
นวทองจะไปอยู่กับจะกลับบ้านไปอยู่กับขุน
แผนหรือนางวันทองจะกลับบ้านไปอยู่กับคุณ
ช้างดีให้นางวันทองเลือกอ่านเลือกว่าจะ
กลับไปอยู่กับใครนะว่าท้องก็คิด
ถ้าคุณช้างไอ้พุทธังไปนะครับ
อ้ายขุนแผนหล่อ
เป็นคนดีแล้วก็เก่งด้วยเก่งด้วยอ่านแต่
ขุนช้างเนี่ยคุณทางไม่หล่อ
ทั่วหน้าไม่หล่อก็อ้วนอ้าหัวล้านครับเออ
หัวล้านอ่ะคุณช้างปวดหัวล้าน
แต่คุณช้างเนี่ยมีเงินคุณช้างรวย
ตอนที่วันทองอยู่กับขุนช้างวันทองไม่ต้อง
ทำงานเพราะว่าคุณช้างมีเงินเยอะใช้เงิน
จ้างให้คนมาทำงานเออตอนนี้พระราชาก็เลย
ถามน้ำมันทองนางวันทองจะไปอยู่กับขุนแผน
หรือไปอยู่กับขุนช้าง
อ่ะนางวันทองก็ไม่ตอบนะว่าท้องก็คิดไม่ก็
บอกว่าจะไปอยู่กับใครดีจะอยู่กับขุนแผน
หรืออยู่กับคุณช้างดีนะมันทองไม่ตอบอยู่
นานถามนานมากแต่น้องก็คิดไม่ได้เลือกไม่
ได้ที่อยู่กับใครดีอ่าพระบาทที่อยู่ด้วย
กัน 3 คนเลยไม่ได้เหรอถามคนไม่ได้ไม่ได้
ไม่ได้
ครับเลือกได้แค่คนเดียวเออออนางวันไหนทำ
ยังไงคะพี่เกือบไม่ได้พระราชาก็เลยก็เลย
สั่งให้ฆ่านางวันทองให้ประหารนางวันทอง
ชายพนาวัลย์เอ่อสมัยโบราณสมัยโบราณผู้
หญิงจะมีสามีได้คนเดียว
ชายผู้หญิงจะมีสามี 1 คน 2 คน 3 คน 4 บท
ไม่ได้ผู้หญิงมีสามีได้คนเดียวแต่นาง
วันทองเลือกไม่ได้
เหรียญนวะทองเลือกไม่ได้พระราชาก็คิดคิด
ว่านางวันทองอยากจะมีสามี 2 คน
ไม่ได้พระราชาก็เลยตัดสินให้ประหารนางวัน
ออก
นางวันทองก็เลยตาๆทั้งสองคนก็เลยเสียใจ
คุณช้างก็เสียใจขุนแผนข้อเสียใจถังคู่อ่า
เรื่องนี้ก็เลยจบลงจบตายเรื่องขุนช้างกับ
ขุนแผนนะครับโอเคอ่าเป็นไงบ้างครับวันนี้
สนุกไหมครับนักเรียน
ฟังตรงไหนไม่เข้าใจ
คอมเมนท์คอมเม้นท์ไว้ข้างล่างได้นะครับ
เออ
แค่ 500 เดี๋ยวคราวหน้าครับกลับมาพบกับ
ครัวตีกับน้องเรียมได้ใหม่ในช่องคอม
เปลี่ยนสโมทัยเดี๋ยวเราจะมาเล่าเรื่อง
อะไรให้ฟังสนุกๆคอยติดตามกันนะครับวันนี้
ครัวตี้แล้วก็น้องเล็ก
ใช่ๆในคลิปหน้ากลับมาเจอกันใหม่ครับผมเขต
ครับอ่าสวัสดีครับไปก่อนแล้วต้าร์สวัสดี
ครับน้องเรียมสิครับนักเรียนบ๊ายบายน
[เพลง]